Grace is a way that you live your life.
We all go through life and we have these different
journeys and we meander in different ways
in and out and ebb and flow, but grace is
a way of appreciating the people that are
around you, the things that are around you
and how you interact with them in a way that's
meaningful, that's purposeful, that's intentional.
You live it in an intentional way you don't
just hey write someone off and just keep moving,
everyone has a purpose on this planet and
we can learn something from everyone.
I mean I learn something every day from my
dog.
I learned patience.
I learn things from people that I would have
never of expected to learn something the janitor
or whomever it is.
And so moving through life in this graceful
way of embracing everything around you so.
Before I could read my mother read to me every
night two books: The Little Engine That Could,
I think I can, I think I can, and Curious
George looking up curiosity.
And I'll never forget I was this little kid
on the football team, the smallest kid probably.
I could run fast but no one ever expected
me to play in the NFL and I never imagined
to play in the NFL because I was just this
small little kid.
But having this never give up I think I can,
I think I can mentality is a gritty way of
ensuring that you're going to reach the dreams
and goals that you have.
Sometimes people don't have expectations for
you because they see you are from a certain
neighborhood or a certain ZIP Code or whatever
and you're looked at as this kid, "Well you're
never going to be an astronaut because you're
from that ZIP Code."
And college, the SATs to get you in college
only predict the first and second year success,
it doesn't predict if you're going to graduate
or how well you're going to do past the first
and second year.
So if we're going to try to build this civilization,
future civilization, Mars, moon, wherever
we're going to go we want to do it with as
many people as we can that have these creative
ideas and our diversity.
And that means that we've got to make sure
that we educate everyone.
And I have a graphic that says you have three
little boys all standing on a box, they're
trying to look at the game.
The little boy in the blue shirt he can't
see the game because he's too short, that's
equality.
But justice is when you have what you need.
When he gets two boxes he can see the game.
One of the kids doesn't even need a box, but
he gets a box anyway.
So let's not be equal, let's give justice
and give you what you need so that you can
see the game.